[Música]
vamos a pasar a nuestra revista de
prensa esta mañana con Alba Santana Alba
Buen día para usted Buenos días Ángela y
vamos a hablar más de la otan es si cabe
porque bolodimir zeleensky estalló ayer
y dijo que la otan no fijaría una fecha
de ingreso para Ucrania y que esto le
parecía absurdo frente a la alianza
Aunque hoy ha cambiado un poco esa
retórica y ha sido mucho más amable y
mucho más conciliador frente a este tema
las editoriales de los medios ucranianos
y estadounidenses también se encuentran
divididas sí podemos decir Ángela que
ayer vimos realmente enfadado a zelensky
y bueno los medios ucranianos siguieron
un poquito de esta línea gubernamental
también no de independent una nos trae
una editorial que titula una o tan
inteligente buscaría el ingreso de
Ucrania el medio ucraniano arranca
diciendo que hay un patrón que se repite
en la lucha de occidente contra Rusia y
en su apoyo a Ucrania y dice que es las
oportunidades o que son las
oportunidades perdidas de que esta
guerra entre Rusia y Ucrania algo
Bastante atrevido según esta editorial
es una el mejor trato que podría recibir
occidente por qué lo explica de la
siguiente manera porque dice que
apoyando a Ucrania debilita a su mayor
amenaza que sería Rusia tan solo a
cambio de lo que serían armas acusa que
las potencias occidentales sin embargo
no reconocen este hecho no lo
reconocerían y también acusa una
respuesta lenta y reluctante por parte
de occidente cuando Ucrania les pide
armas entonces dice que esta escasez de
armas También estaría debilitando o
empeorando la contraofensiva ucraniana
contra Rusia y dice cito textualmente
parece que occidente trata la
solicitudes de Ucrania como demandas y
razonables mientras que Ucrania solo
está pidiendo lo que necesita para
sobrevivir y con su supervivencia
también protege a occidente en este
también dice esta editorial que sería un
error que la otan solo diera unas
concesiones simbólicas porque sería algo
ventajoso según la editorial para el
kremlin mientras que compromiso reales
significarían un golpe para el kremlin
Incluso si se llega a este esta
editorial defiende escala un poquito el
tono a un conflicto directo entre Rusia
y occidente y dice para cerrar Se trata
de envalentonar a Rusia o aplastar su
ambición
bueno Alba de todas maneras el
presidente ha dicho hoy se les Quique
entiende que al ser un país en guerra
todavía no sean adheridos a la otan
cabría preguntarnos también si esto
tiene más un tono irónico o un tono
realmente comprensivo pues como lo dijo
el mismo mandatario pero bueno vamos a
hacer un cambio de tema para pasar al
Reino Unido porque este es un caso que
se ha vuelto muy mediático en el
presentador estrella de la bbc que fue
acusado y también que fue suspendido por
pagar a un menor por fotos sexuales y
ahora se ve envuelto en otro caso de
acoso a otro menor es todo lo dicen los
medios locales Así es Ángela la baby Sí
y la cadena complicada en todo este
escándalo titula presentador de la bbc
mandó mensajes abusivos abusivos a un
segundo menor o a una segunda menor
porque recordemos que todas estas
identidades están protegiendo por tema
de intimidad y preservación la historia
del escándalo de la bbc continúa y lejos
de parecer terminar parece que se agrava
incluso otro menor o menor ha acusado
que este presentador de la bbc a un bajo
condición de anonimato el mismo también
lo habría contactado o la habría
contactado a través de una aplicación de
citas y habría intentado presionar para
que se vieran en a persona cuando la
víctima insinuó que podría delatarlo el
presentador le mandó un mensaje
amenazantes y también insultos la bbc
asegura que ha visto pruebas sobre lo
que estamos comentando y se ha puesto en
contacto con el abogado del presentador
pero no ha obtenido respuesta también
aprovechado esta cadena británica
Pública para defender su manejo de la
situación y asegurar que intentó
contactar dos veces con la familia antes
de que la familia adhiera esta exclusiva
de San recordemos el sábado pasado y
bueno ahora vamos a seguir también con
que titula este tabloide que dio la
exclusiva en su momento el presentador
de la baby sí se saltó la restricciones
de la pandemia para quedar con una o una
joven el tabloide que sigue trabajando
en esas exclusivas dice que habría
visitado el presentador a uno a una de
sus citas durante la pandemia de
covid-19 saltándose entonces las
restricciones también asegura que fue la
víctima dice que fue a su apartamento y
que le dijo que no pero que él fue muy
insistente entonces aquí vemos también
un poquito esta fina esa delgada línea
entre lo que sería la intimidad de esta
persona que está acusada y las
acusaciones también con base por eso
tampoco se ha hecho público este nombre
del presentador bueno no para de llover
sobre la bbc y este caso tendrá por
supuesto que aclararse esperemos en un
futuro próximo Alba Pero tenemos más
temas ustedes nos trae también un asunto
sobre cisjordania concretamente iríamos
a jenín donde según una fotogalería que
ha publicado el medio al jazzira la vida
vuelve poco a la normalidad si es que se
le puede llamar normalidad a la forma en
que sobreviven los ciudadanos en después
de la redada israelí Así es Ángela aquí
se tiene que debatir un poquito no sobre
si esto se puede considerar normalidad o
no Porque recordemos que janin es un
campo de refugiados Bueno al yacira nos
trae esta fotogalería que titula la vida
cotidiana vuelve al campo de llenin tras
el asalto israelí nos cuenta un poquito
pues esto que hablábamos de cómo se ha
vuelto a la cotidianidad
y tras la redada israelí en la localidad
bajo el pretexto de que buscarían a
supuestos terroristas que luchaban por
el estado de Palestina y que terminó
cobrándose la vida de al menos dos de
palestinos y una soldado israelí en
estas fotos podemos ver la destrucción
que dejó tras de Sí esta redada también
tumbas con flores contra las víctimas o
también carteles o fotos de los
combatientes Eso sí por el estado
palestino que perecieron durante la
redada de este ejército israelí
recordemos que jenning es uno de los
campos de refugiados que tiene una tasa
de desempleo a más alta de toda
cirjordania entonces en medio de toda
esta pobreza Los palestinos están
intentando retomar sus vidas con la
mayor normalidad posible bueno Este es
un caso que le agradezco algo por traer
a la mesa Porque después de las redadas
de ninine hemos tenido muchos titulares
al respecto y es bueno mantener la
discusión alrededor de este tema no y
bueno tiene un cierre que está bien
particular y que se sale completamente
de lo que hemos conversado hasta ahora y
tiene que ver con Brasil y con el
expresidente Jair bolsonaro de extrema
derecha que abrió una tienda de
recuerdos o de souvenirs sí totalmente
de Guardian titula es hora de la fiesta
Yahir bolsonaro Abre una tienda online
temática y Bueno aquí puedes conseguir
de todo desde kits de fiesta hasta
jarras de cerveza con la cara de Jair
bolsonaro y obviamente tiene sus lemas
más predilectos como Brasil por encima
de todos y Dios a por encima de todos y
bueno este es el emprendimiento del
expresidente de extrema derecha Bueno
pues hay cualquier cantidad de maneras
de hacer publicidad Alba Así que gracias
por ese Dato curioso y le deseo que
tenga un feliz día nos vemos mañana nos
vemos mañana Ángela